hey hey and welcome back to terraria
epic brah look at IKEA tower just look
at it look at this beauty so many people
choose to live here look how many people
live inside this beautiful hotel
I guess it's hotel like here at this
point it's amazing except you Connor no
one wants to hear calling there you can
leave now so you guys told me that if I
put the handgun here he's like oh you
can make a Phoenix blaster seems pretty
good but we need hellstone bars to make
it where you get hell stone well of
course in hell let's go gamers hopefully
this all works okay little awkward
making our way downtown walking fast
faces pass and I'm home BAM getting
scared getting scared what oh my god
hey Connor your lowlife weasel I just
thought I'd say that let's go again
gamers hate car Jesus scared me okay
it's coming up there it is okay it's
important that you make your passage to
Hell safe as possible because you never
you never know what's gonna happen all
right here we go
hey hey I wonder what kind of people I
meet here that's so weird
everyone in Hell is a verified Twitter
account I'm at dared to make this jump
oh yes I do baby okay so now I have I
also have this now I'm sitting skull so
I should be able to not take damage
never mind never mind I'm literally on
fire okay yeah this is a hailstone out
stop a mine hellstone all day a mine has
stolen all night
okay I got it make sure I get it as well
yes oh my god I'm dying are you kidding
me how many did I get that I get it
enough oh nice okay so we can make it
now nevermind
yes suck it Connor I want to make this
can I make it now yes okay it's a molten
helmet damn that's really good okay I
made a PP I made it
beep begun can I use it I don't know why
it's so funny it's like as if there were
guns in Minecraft or something I think
one of these guys sells gun-related it's
the one with a southern accent I think
alright alright let's head out we're
going to the jungle there's a boss
battle in there that I really we really
want to do Oh actually I forgot damn I
need to talk to stinky Corner stinky so
I think he can improve my shield as well
just with an obsidian skull Oh epic I
have that nice that's really good
immunity to knock back immunity to fire
blocks yeah hey Bonnie
what is wrong with me I'm so sorry I
apologize deeply
that looks rad strange plant okay oh god
it's coming right for me oh thank god
I also have a flare gun I don't know if
that's good or not that's kind of cool
maybe I shouldn't waste it a lot how
many weapons there are it's just like so
many ways to play it if he's like
minecraft meets darks whoa oK we've
entered the jungle gamers sorry mr.
beast but I need to build another house
here suck a PP do it okay
bed okay does it work yes
okay so now we have our little base here
and that means if we die which I never
do oh god I hate the bats oh yeah let's
go down and find this stinky Queen beer
or whatever
[Music]
oh wow okay I don't know you could do
that that's awesome
manslaughter
hey we got a chest here which I've
clearly used already well what is this
this is another biome what is this what
is this granite whoa night-vision helmet
what oh wow that works so well you
kidding me
what is this improves vision well that
was a lie
okay this look man what is this flipper
ability to swim okay
teleport see to random location that's
funny I think it's time we just start
bombing shooting it's just fun and I
like it I like when people go poopoo I
bomb ball day I bomb ball night okay a
lot of treasure in the jungle a 10%
movement speed okay oh god I'm drowning
I didn't realize Oh God no air sweet air
oh there it is oh god too busy getting
lewd all right good thing we build a
house how do I find the B some water -
Jesus Christ
whoa purple item I've never seen they
write what was it immunity to poison
lame okay I still see bees as long as
there's bees there's hope to kill more
of them yes English oh hello they're
throwing a party without me
nice more health whoa oh this is a
dynamite it go boom boom okay boom oh
god no what so much more than I thought
I think I have to return home I had too
much stuff on me and I
there was a party without me invitation
name where party is they all have little
party hats
that's so cute wow what a party
everyone's just chilly
oh there's balloons in the background
this game is adorable you invited all my
friends good thinking
okay so I can make these nice nice I can
climb walls now nice I can make diving
gear that's so cool
hoo I can almost make lightning boots
cool what's an anklet okay teleport to
random location three two one go
where am i oh no I made a mistake
I've just ended that's a man it's so fun
too
it's like when I find a game I really
like the fact that I can play it as a
living is always like mind-blowing to me
alright we're back in our gorgeous
little house absolutely gorgeous
where the B where B am i getting trolled
yes there actually no being here
maybe the bees by the honey of course
I'm so stupid they must be right the
queen bee is in the honey of course oh
my god I'm so stupid
woah oh they don't like that oh yes look
at that so she must be one of these Oh
what is that is that a queen bee has
awoken
oh god that's terrifying alright I'm
gonna shoot her I should have built
platforms I'm from the hood
mother-fricker yeah
you can't hurt what is already filled
with hurt and death death Queen Bee has
been defeated yeah I did it all by
myself
if only took me so long to understand
bee wax you should drop anything good B
need a grenade explodes into swarming
bees
why does honey look like pixelated
genitals in anime because it's from horn
nyet
I'm sorry 340 life now see there's more
be stuff there and there
wait it dropped the weapon okay look I'm
the B master now
I killed the remaining bees because they
gave me this armor so now I'm a pig
next thing I want to do is I want to go
to the snow area I don't think we've
been there all right here we go
I don't know what's down here bro is
that blood what is this why is there
Lilly nothing down here
maybe there's something epic down here
like who knows who's keeping track I
don't know okay well I just kind of
sucks
there's nothing here this is why I left
Sweden water walking this okay no oh God
you idiot
ah dammit hey guys help me blade
terraria hey hey
yeah kill the Queen B yeah got the full
armor it's so easy I killed three of
them all right this is new it's a touch
what is that a sheep rash flurry
superfast I don't really know what to do
at this point I feel like I've done
everything all right let's go to hell
gamers we
[Music]
oh well this is awkward
okay are they're killing my bees I'm
dare you dope
oh they're invincible that's something
awesome I like them they're cute I'm not
sure where to go to be on Oh God not
there that was close
oh Jesus I don't see any health stuff oh
wait they're everywhere sorry I don't
know what's hurting we have two tanks
they're so small those things I hate
them
whoa what is that whoa whoa what just
happened there okay I'll take it I'll
take it
hello mr. demon let me just break into
your house because that's what people do
apparently done I hate how I can't see
what lava is in the foreground and
what's in the background it's really
hard to talk whoa Jesus how can I open
door thank you
did I get a Woody doll I think I got one
okay we got one oh nice we got one so
now I just throw him in lava and epic
fun time begins [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
drop it in lava calm down gamers I want
to try and get the better armor first
because I think I can get that quite
easily
I love the Hornets they're so good the
black chest I don't see a black chest
you mean that one where open the chest
what chest that's where you guys are
smoking top left don't ever call me
dummy only I can call myself dummy this
one Oh got it
he'll bow helloween Bowl
lame garbage
thanks for the garbage more hellstone
give me give me give me nice this is a
good spot
nice just a couple more I think we
should be good I have 55 maybe that's
okay hey an obsidian bed once it
actually maybe I'll keep it
oh god I only gave me 18
I can make a molten helmet oh wow
molten fury I can make the Greaves
15 damn an obsidian okay there it is
bottled water fire blossom water leaf
and obsidian how do I get bottled water
from sand okay I knew that I can make
glass okay and how do I make it a bottle
oh there we go now can I make potion
question mark hey Connor
what's it gotta take let's go to the
nearest source of water there's no water
oh my god are there no water on their
surface I have three Hornets epic I
guess this water literally right there
well that was a lot easier or it has to
be under surface what is happening why
not it's like having 500 people yelling
at you to do something listen if you
guys were consistent that'd be a lot of
help more helpful okay oh you literally
just crafted in the water that makes
sense that's so dumb oh my all right
almost a where do I make this [ __ ]
potion there it is
thank God I can make three nice things
well that was fun
torture good thing I saved the Sun to be
honest okay fart in the bottle people
say so cloud in a bottle and fart in a
jar violent cloud really be a violent
fart then please say yes notice does
that not make it worse I can't already
double Jim now it's fleeting fart in a
jar allows holders the double jump I
could already do that oh great excellent
it's better yeah I know it's better
alright for them 12 years sorry 9 year
olds I'm so I mean 19 year olds okay so
let's make sure we drink the potion well
let's do a little test here I'm alive
excellent alright just got to make sure
I look at that can I blow these up or is
everyone saying F all that chat with the
stream and done okay well this is about
500 times easier Jesus I wonder how my
bees are doing in this lava they do not
drink the potion
doesn't matter how do you fart in lava
as well
no that was four minutes had to have it
up an idiot all right that was 105 that
only gives 35 but I can craft and staff
nice
what else can I make I can make the
breast plate nice and that's it for now
okay let's drop down again gamers how
many amps can it happen you can all have
one imp I got the emptying you guys were
begging about I got the chest plays and
I got the legs need a bit more I want
more cuz I got hope take deep breaths
shut up
I don't have the molten pickaxe yet I
have not made the molten pickaxe yet
okay I'm drinking fart sound I swear to
God
so dumb we hit rock bottom gamers here
it is what happens if you go down rock
bottom question mark kind of want to try
it low key
I'm rock bottom gamers feelsgoodman
making fart noises hey hey hey hey
alright so someone said I can
right-click on the Imps how do I put
them back I want more imps Oh somehow I
have more now I don't know how that
happened okay anyway helper barrage damn
son alright now we can make the helmet
helmet done okay let's switch out the
bee outfit as much as I like the bee
outfit moulton is where it's at gamers
alright set bonus 70 with extra Mellie
Mellie damaged jesus [ __ ] christ
which weapon then fatal fire a great
sword er I feel like I have to cut this
- cool
make the night's edge what the [ __ ] did
I make then woah look at that massive
dude that's woah woah bro show this
sword to Connor Connor hey Connor look
up this sword pretty epic right what I
can make nights edge I have them
I don't know I just need blade of grass
and I need the blood butchery all right
I clearly don't have that okay damn that
sound though all right I'll show to him
and he says oh I can make it through a
light Spain Muramasa and blade of grass
so I just need blade of grass and I do I
have a Muramasa yeah I've been in the
jungle so much today all right here we
are
what the [ __ ] are you some girl in my
house you say that you're a negro Trixie
she's definitely a girl lava lamp
what party hat oh is this another Hornet
yeah oh did I actually feel and blow it
up by accident
welcome to the hood [ __ ] yeah
Yee 360 baby all right two more singers
then I'm outies all right this is our
last yes I am out get the Frick out of
my house I'm playing Terraria nice
celebratory fart okay grass sword done
Connor Connor smother should I just be
able to craft it where is my sword huh I
thought I had them all Connor you lying
punch demon altering corruption well
well well
look like we have for an adventure again
well well well time to play some beach
ball well well well look like we're
having some fun with our demon and yeah
yeah
yeah plain beach ball oh yeah
damn the farts are really like they
really make me flinch
three two one let's go blippi blippi
blippi your mama oh yeah did it pain
suffer pain suffer home time play with
ball show to Connor the sword again a
garnet egg got broken hero sword where
the [ __ ] am I gonna find that so I
clearly can't have it now so shut the
[ __ ] up then have you heard of that have
you heard of being quiet good reef or
sword okay all right
it's bad enough and break it costs okay
reforge I did it whoo okay let's do in
that demonic that's pretty good isn't it
I'll go with that whenever's if I show
Connor the whole thing of himself he
doesn't want to hear it there's an aglet
and surfers just near old bed oh you
mean my old house you've got enough
[ __ ] lie to me
oh thanks guys
yes damn whoever remember that props to
you man that's [ __ ] funny oh [ __ ]
it's so expensive I didn't realize I
just wasted so much money I thought it
was like one goal before own little Oh
rest in peace money no rest in pieces
it's fine I know how to farm money in
this game it's okay it's all good I'm
not crying I'm not crying show Connor
I'm stick up [ __ ] Connor I'm gonna
throw his thing in the lava and be done
with it chop chop chop
hey hey Bridge a super long one all
right
this will be the most dangerous bridge
of all time so between here would that
make sense we're gonna be the longest
bridge okay I want it to be one pretty
platform okay don't judge me it has to
be pretty shut up with the bridge
building a bridge it's actually not bad
not a bad kid this most beautiful bridge
this town has ever seen build the bridge
they said okay I am complain more they
do okay that's cool all right time to
throw Connor and lava yeah let's do it
three two one king bats by Connor never
like to you bye
of dude he kills people and McKay's
slinging terraria boyfriend confirmed
sorry for Xia they have Conner you rich
hey Conner it's not your house don't
think so
only I can kill Connor backup where's
Connor where's that scumbag come back
Connor
there you are you scumbag what if I
don't want Connor in here get out of my
house you don't live here why have you
been not telling me
Connor you piece of [ __ ] I hate you
one day one day you'll learn
screw him and screw you Connor what she
went to hell okay I'm scared what do I
do
do I run what do I do yeah what the hell
he's shooting me Obi nades oh jesus
crisis [ __ ] terrifying yeah yeah
death
I might famishing him
I like I'm not doing enough Emmet I feel
like I did not build this bridge long
enough this bridge is not long enough
chief liars
oh my god
never doubted for a second that I would
not be able to do it wow that was so
easy first right yeah all right okay
literally the entire shot went it's it's
long enough you got it
Oh God ooh Summoner ooh ooh ooh should I
summon him again our gamers I'm gonna
end that there see you guys on the flip
you floppy
all right smash like you enjoyed that
episode and and subscribe epically check
out the merch cyka blyat and bye bye
[Music]
now you are entering a new era where you
shall craft the whole poop
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming marzia Edgar and buttons need
you
the diaper you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne
the game to play I'm not supposed to
have my opinion about that but the
prices
[Music]
you